friends is one of the most beloved
sitcoms of all time
and continues to bring new fans in
droves as it's become readily available
to stream online 24 hours a day for 10
seasons the namesake new york-based
friends navigate work
romantic relationships and of course
friendships that frequently
intertwine with one another when the
series begins the group
are all in their mid-20s so it makes
sense that they often discuss
their love lives which might make for
some uncomfortable moments if you're
watching friends with your parents
that said though most of the time the
series doesn't cross the line
even though it's a largely
family-friendly sitcom about dealing
with life and love in new york city
friends isn't always squeaky clean there
are two
scenes from the show that stick out
amongst all the others
once that fans watching back then
thought went too far and fans today
still talk about in season sevens the
one with ross and monica's cousin
denise richards guest stars as you
guessed it
ross and monica's cousin richards plays
cassie
a gorgeous blonde who dazzles almost
everyone she comes into contact with
especially as she tosses her hair from
side to side while staying with monica
and chandler
cassie has to leave because chandler
can't stop staring at her
cassie goes to stay with ross instead
but the situation only gets worse
as thought nearly turns to action simply
put
ross is attracted to cassie his literal
cousin
in the same way chandler is and toys
with the idea of making a move on her
viewers are treated to ross's
cringe-inducing inner monologue as he
debates going in for a kiss
to everyone's shock and horror ross
eventually does try to lock lips with
cassie while they're sitting on the
couch and watching a movie
after a very long pause ross offers this
excuse
i i haven't had sex in a very long time
that's no excuse even if the person
you're trying to smooch isn't your
cousin
and the fact that ross and cassie truly
are blood-related makes the moment
so much worse journalist and black gal's
live-in podcast co-host victoria sunusi
spoke for the masses when she tweeted
accompanied by a string of woozy face
emojis
ross kissed his cousin i've had enough
of this man
the attempted kiss with cassie made
metro's list of the 10 times ross was
quote
actually the worst human being ever
writer tilly pierce argued not only were
ross's actions toward her
a little predatory having her move into
his apartment after chandler and joey
started getting weird
they were bordering on the incestuous he
was also the only one to actually make a
move on her which again
all kinds of gross and just ugg let's
move on from this already because we've
got the creeps
even the most arden of friends fans have
pinned frost as being the worst of the
bunch
so it's unfortunately no surprise that
another of the series's scenes
that went too far has ross at its center
in the season 10 episode the one where
the stripper cries
siblings ross and monaco learned that
they accidentally kissed one another
back in college
as ross tells it it was a weekend in
1987 when monica and rachel visited ross
and chandler at school
chandler ended up kissing rachel that
night and ross is only finding out about
it now
he's upset because it was the same night
he kissed rachel for the first time
or so he thought ross believed that it
was rachel lying on his bed
buried under a pile of other people's
coats and when he went to kiss her
forehead he accidentally got her lips
since it was so dark the person he
thought was rachel kissed him back
and the moment was forever cemented in
ross's memory as part of his
and rachel's love story when ross
recounts the events of the evening
chandler is confused since he knows
rachel was sleeping in his bed instead
and monica she's horrified realizing
that her own brother was her midnight
mystery kisser and worst of all her
first kiss
ever what did i marry into
though the kiss happened off screen
viewers were still disgusted at the plot
point
one fan on twitter wrote why did they do
that so
painfully gross another tweeted that
moment when ross and monica kissed when
ross was in college
hashtag ew couldn't have said it better
ourselves
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite classic sitcoms are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one